is react to the pandemic with travel
bans lockdowns fighting for every life
in one of germany's coronavirus hotspots
some european countries are starting to
relax lockdown restrictions while others
are tiny
No is not the time to relax measures
Europe is in lockdown schools businesses
restaurants and factories have all been
shuttered for weeks now people are
demoralized with the arrival of spring
they've been enjoying what they still
can the Sun in the park some fresh air
but many are missing a sense of
community some countries like Denmark
and Austria are already beginning to
lose in the most severe restrictions
others think it is too early for that
now what do experts say is the virus
under control can public life returned
to normal and will the warmer
temperatures now arriving in the
northern hemisphere slow the spread of
the disease
these are some of the questions we'll
discuss in this edition of Covey's 19
special here on DW news I'm Chris Cobra
and Berlin is good to have you with us
now the longer the shutdown is in place
the more pressing becomes the question
when can strict social distancing
measures be eased here in Germany public
officials are yet to decide on an
official strategy so let's get an
expert's view to be escort is a
professor of public health and
epidemiology at Berlin's Charlotte a
hospital welcome to our program to be us
let's talk about the weather first here
there have been some including the US
president saying that rising
temperatures are bad for the virus
are they well if you look at the areas
that report infections and if you see
the spread of the virus there's really
no differences between regions that are
warmer and regions that are colder so I
think the virus is really not affected
by temperature it is true that during
the cold weather season that the skin
inside the nose inside your throat is
more susceptible for getting an
infection that may be a factor but I
don't think that the virus is really
affected by temperature so springtime
meaning it's not necessarily a bad time
for Corona it's not a bad time for the
virus it's a good time for for us and
enjoying the Sun and hopefully getting
some fresh air and certainly the
sunshine helps certainly for the moon so
it's a good time for all of us it's a
spring right now
for a virus I don't think that makes
much of a difference Toby as the number
of reported cases in Germany is
declining Italy in Spain the country's
hardest hit here in Europe are reporting
receding death numbers where are we in
the time line of this pandemic what I
think one has to understand that the
virus cannot be stopped the reasons why
these measures and the physical contact
restrictions are in place is to allow
the healthcare system to brief and some
regions even in Germany we know that
hospitals are really on the edge and so
this was the reason why we certainly
supported these these measures now the
epidemic is really over if the so-called
health community is reached and that is
a long way to go so if now we would like
some measures it does not mean that the
virus is gone the virus is still there
and we have to deal with the virus for
quite some time until we have
vaccinations available or until enough
people have been infected with the virus
and have immunity against the virus
nevertheless the severe social
distancing measures they are taking
their toll on people a number of public
officials here in Germany and other
places are talking about lifting some of
the strictest countermeasures is it the
right time to do that well scientists
and many experts and politicians are
discussing this obviously and nobody
likes to put this really hard measures
into into place this is the right time
will be in three weeks in two weeks and
ten days nobody really can tell what I
think is a good time now to discuss how
we can lift these restrictions and how
we can move into the future as you know
there biomedical data but also other
data economic data social data
psychological data and all of these is
not really helpful for the health of the
people so we have to really start to
think on how we move on and to really
start to go back to a life that is
certainly not a normal life that we've
used to
but to a life that makes sense and makes
us starting businesses again and
allowing maybe kids to go to school so I
think it's a good time to discuss this
right now all right let's do it let's
talk about the how Germany's Academy of
Science is one of the most renowned
research institutions in the country
says primary and secondary schools
should gradually open again and it
should be mandatory for people to wear
face masks on public transportation what
is your take on that I think these are
very good and reasonable suggestions
many experts from various fields have
been involved in these recommendations
and I think that those are really good
starting points we all have to
understand however that if restrictions
are lifted that we may see an effect of
the healthcare system again and then we
have to increase some of the
restrictions potentially so this will be
in all enough for some time we have to
evaluate this very carefully in the
experts are doing this to to recommend
specific measures to the politicians who
then have to make their decisions but I
think the recommendation of the national
academy of science are really reasonable
and a good starting point also it is
important that I said that we should not
really isolate specific groups such as
the elderly or such as people with
certain medical conditions I think that
was also a very important state and to
be us briefly what are the most
important aspects of such a strategy of
easing these restrictions well it is we
really have to look what is possible and
people what they can do I think we all
as a society understood the importance
of defeating this virus and the
importance of the application of the
healthcare system so I think we should
also count on on this society that they
really work with everyone to make this
happen
epidemiologist Toby escort thank you for
talking to DW thank you so the
discussion over when and how to exit the
lockdown is still waging meanwhile
spring
arrived in many countries in Europe and
at least in Germany people try to make
the best of their situation over the
Easter weekend which meant catching some
rays while trying not to catch the virus
spring has come and in parks across
Germany you wouldn't necessarily know
that the country is in lockdown having
spent weeks cooped up indoors many
people are experiencing a fresh
appreciation for nature luxury being
outside but of course I'm not meeting
friends or socializing it has a calming
effect it's relaxing for me it's
liberating to be out in nature in
Germany you are still allowed to go out
alone or with one other person
what about stew exercise or just to
breathe in some fresh air but even when
you're soaking in the spring Sun you
still need to make sure you're sticking
to social distancing rules an outer man
who certainly wishes he'd have more time
for a nice walk in the park but our
resident Corona expert Derek Williams
has been very busy thinking about and
answering the questions you sent us
here's our latest installment can you
get the corona virus and not show any
symptoms based on what we know right now
it looks like around one out of every
six people that catches kovat 19 gets
seriously ill and develops difficulties
with breathing symptoms and others who
have tested positive for the disease
range from serious to very mild and some
people who test positive have no
symptoms at all the Center for Disease
Control in the u.s. believes as many as
one in four people who get the disease
show no symptoms
now that's vital information to have as
asymptomatic carriers might remain
perfectly healthy themselves but
contribute dramatically to transmission
knowing how many people are asymptomatic
would also help us nail down the real
mortality rate of the virus which
continues to be guesstimated and finally
it's important in terms of fighting the
disease if we can figure out why some
people don't get sick that information
could help us in the race to develop
therapies could surviving covered 19 be
linked to your DNA this question is
closely tied to the question of why some
people can carry the disease but are are
asymptomatic from what we've seen so far
the corona virus infects everyone but
some people don't develop symptoms and
that probably has to do with their
genetic makeup past research has shown
the genetics do have an influence on the
course of viral infections and
scientists are looking at some key genes
very closely in the coded 19 pandemic
especially the ones that encode for and
control the expression of an enzyme in
the cell membrane called ace 2 its what
the corona virus uses as a gateway to
get into the cell could variations there
make some people more susceptible than
others maybe it's pretty unlikely though
that there will be a single genetic
variant that determines whether you get
a mild or severe case of kovat 19 the
first wide-scale research studies in the
area are ramping up now but they'll take
time to carry out and evaluate and if
you have a question for us about the
virus simply post it in the comment
section of our DW youtube channel and
that wraps up today's edition of kovat
19 special for more on the pandemic do
check out our social media channels and
our website that's DW comm which has
dedicated kovat 19 pages in 30 languages
I'm Chris Cobra and bulan thanks for
watching and before we let you go many
scientists around the world are calling
on governments to provide people with
face masks if they intend on easing
lockdown restrictions now Taiwan seems
to be a step
hedaan this authorities there have set
up a vending machines where people can
scan their health insurance insurance
cards in order to pick up their
fortnightly ration of nine masks an idea
other countries may well wish to adopt
themselves
[Music]
you